Bangladesh the land of rivers
with nearly 160 million people it's one
of the most densely populated countries
in the world
but the battle for resources is causing
species to die out pollution is
destroying rivers and wetlands are
drying up
in the last two decades these areas have
undergone a huge transformation people
are beginning to recognize the need to
take action to save the environment
thirty years ago scientists would see
hundreds of dolphins on the baurel River
today he needs to be patient if he wants
to catch a glimpse of a single one
inaudible is the people's they call it
shishu actually she should his child
Ganges dolphins are often solitary
creatures when the rainy season comes
they move upstream but that puts them in
danger due to climate change and other
factors our important viewers I have
Dalton leaves
although most isolated in important
areas also the migrating here at the
arrow and the became and then George and
people are responsible dams and locks
have rested as much water as possible
from the land cutting off the natural
paths of dolphins and fish Bangladesh
lives off its fertile alluvial deposits
almost half the population works in
agriculture paddy fields dominate the
landscape
nowadays the wetlands no longer live up
to their name the land is dried up in
the fish are gone for people in the
poplar region it's a disaster more than
300 men and women are digging out to
dried up branch a river by hand
Nazim Akram is helping my job is to look
after the worries and concerns of the
workers one of the baby's cries I check
on them and if someone's thirsty I bring
them water the project allows people
like nazim ax Akram to earn some money
the scheme aims to restore and protect
34 wetlands for many and many species to
species reappears after they discover
some those disappeared people after the
excavation they'll cough again they will
breed again and by the worse it will be
necessary but to make it work
the fishermen need to take an active
role it's up to them to conserve the
stock of fish but the small amount they
manage to catch these days is hardly
enough to live on but I'm shuttin hunter
has been fishing here for over 50 years
we caught them all sold them and wiped
them out that's how it is the fish have
disappeared and we're in despair there's
no longer any connection to the rivers
he's worried about his children's future
when he can he helps out with the
environmental protection project the
poles are designed to stop Nets being
cast it's an ideal spawning area for
fish
birds and bats find a refuge here this
evening Nasima Akram has arranged a
meeting for all the women in the village
the project has allowed her to learn new
skills she wants to get things moving as
a woman that takes courage the biggest
change for me personally is that I never
used to go out now I address other women
speak about the environment and think
about how we can preserve the flora and
fauna of the wetlands I also occupy
myself with women's rights I didn't know
anything about all that before but not
everyone can afford to take part in
sustainable farming many people have
simply moved away from rural areas to
work in the Bangladeshi capital Dhaka
some former fishermen now make a living
pulling rickshaws overpopulation and a
battle for resources are not the only
issues which present a problem to the
German project coordinator Otilia
Mustafa the dilemma we're facing is that
often feeding the population here in
Bangladesh comes at the expense of
biodiversity that's a challenge because
there are poor people here who really
rely on these resources to survive and
at that point it's a question of whether
or not you can afford to do without the
final 20 30 percent of your catch Nasima
are calm and her family have made a
commitment to do just that at least as
long as the project is running and they
can make money from it the fish catch
here has already fallen by 75% if the
rest of the stock is to be protected
the fishermen need alternatives
and what about the Ganges dolphin there
are now three protected areas for them
sometimes as some people start to
harvest it but Fisher's protect them the
sub positive site they try to conserve
in this area
but we have enough to do for them we
will dust we started